hello and welcome to
a special edition of spectator tv
and we just have the final ballot of the
parliamentary rounds and myself katie
balls and james forsyth are going to
discuss what it means
and ultimately if we look at the results
of this penny morgan has been knocked
out that means that rishi sunak and liz
trust are into the final two and do so
many questions you have about what
happens next
james what's your initial thoughts on
seeing their results
so
richard c knight talked about by a bit
more than people thought i think the
speculation of parliament earlier today
was that the three candidates would be
quite closely bunched up together
um
then uh
penny richard got 137. uh liz trusts in
second and 113 and penny more than 105.
so very little between the third place
and second place
uh and i think that you know in some
ways this was a as you said this was
after coming about not went out and
given that at that point his trust was
within single digits of penny more than
it always seemed likely that she would
be able to get over the line
i mean the penny morgan campaign feel
that uh the trust campaign kind of
pushed some of the stuff that has done
paying more a lot of damage in in recent
days
um
but now we go on to this sunac trusts
membership round liz stross will start
that as a favorite um but there is a
kind of clear intellectual divide
between the two of them which we've
already seen in these debates which is
you know richardson argues two things
really that one the immediate priority
has to be controlling inflation and
secondly that you can't have something
for nothing uh liz ross's argument is
that you know uh the most impressive
thing is to get growth going and she's
gonna slash taxes to do that
and she's not gonna bring back austerity
and she's gonna spend more on defense
and we're now looking ahead to the next
stage of the contest so
uh in theory you could be having a bit
of a pause at the moment um effectively
uh this contest will run for quite a
long time you know for july through
august the victor will not be announced
to
early september
but james is ultimately in the interest
of particularly risky cena to get going
quite quickly isn't it because right now
he is behind liz trust on all membership
polling you con home in all their
polling and obviously take polling as
ever with a pinch of salt having a
run-off that he would lose to her and
the ballots go in early august so does
that mean that actually the window to
try and win hearts change mines is
smaller than it first seems yeah the
theory is that the tory voters are um
are
are kind of people who reply by return
of post when they send their postal
ballots and so you've really got you
know that that once you get towards the
middle of august the majority of members
will have voted already so that front
loads this contest you know um there is
a bbc debate on on monday night there's
a first hosting's tomorrow and so you
might think that you know the two
campaigns will wanna you know go home
uh you know have a drink celebrate this
moment no instead you know it is
straight back at it because
it you know by the end of august i think
you know there'll be very few toy
members who haven't voted it's at the
start of this contest that the most
minds will be open to being changed and
a slight question i think we have half
answers one of the questions that come
in is has come in is when does voting
start for party members and does that
timing matter so just to clarify as soon
as they receive their ballots in early
august they can vote yes um there has
been a story today which i haven't had a
chance to check on which is
they would be able to vote by post and
then change their vote later on online
but i can't if that is true that that
tries to be a recipe for a certain
amount of confusion um but
but i certainly think that that both
campaigns are operating on the
assumption that it's the opening weeks
of the campaign that matters the most
and then we've been talking about the
polling of the parties as the question
has just come images how much have mps
voting be influenced by polls of
membership and the public
watching the answer to those um rishi
cena ultimately probably i mean i think
there there is mixed polling what the
general public think that i think there
was a general uh
perhaps lack of excitement but any
candidate but a lot of the polling is
put rishi scenic in the best place
amongst the public if you think about
the snap verdict on on the debate um
on sunday uh
meanwhile the membership polling has put
liz trust in a much better place has
that been influencing mps when working
out where they're gonna switch who
they're gonna back so i think it's had a
decisive impact on mps because you know
kenny bad knock who got knocked out uh
it was the days of rolling through was
it yesterday she got knocked out yes
yesterday um uh it's only wednesday oh
god is that um
she yeah napoleon suggested that she
would win with the membership so um
but i think i think there are the penny
morgan campus this morning were quite
aggressively making the argument to mps
that liz trust couldn't win a general
election so don't don't put her into the
final two
um
and and i mean that that has an effect
on some of these i mean there are other
mps who uh look at liz ross and see her
ahead of the members and think well if
that's you know the members want that
that's he should pick
i think now the the big question now i
think is you know this is now over to
the members you know mps now only have
one vote as a member of their local
association some of them will have two
votes because they'll be a member of
their association their constituency and
where they live in london but
it will become a
a quite and i think i think the big
question is
what is going to
influence them uh and
what
and i think you will see a lot of uh
attempts to come here
these hostings you know and there's a
and i think it's quite interesting that
the first one tomorrow is with
conservative councillors because yeah i
think councils and people like that will
now almost have as much if not more
influence on this contest as mps because
you know people can turn yeah this might
be nothing to say some people who are
talking members are not are
are are not you know they would they
will look to other people in the
association for like what what do you
think are lecturing um i i was
interested i was talking to someone
who's a association chairman in a
prosperous seat in south england
yesterday and they were saying that they
hadn't talked to their members yet but
they were struck talking to their
officers you know but the local
elections there had left where they got
run a lot closer than they had
previously had left a big impression on
them now let's do two questions at once
is rishi a safer pair of hands than this
and is there any realistic chance that
any winner can unite the party i'll take
the first one james you take the second
um so i think on that on that first
question about who is the safer pair of
hands i mean i think ultimately both are
experienced cabinet ministers actually
liz trust is longer serving if you think
about how long she's been in cabinet
remember she's doing that but richie
scenic has been in a more senior role in
the sense of being chancellor um i think
that rishi scenic's plan as james was
saying of you know one of fiscal
responsibility i
i think you could say that
liz trust's plan for the economy is more
radical
than rishi sunax and and i imagine i i
think there was a sense amongst mps that
they have probably a greater idea of
however she's your neck would govern
partly because he has been so key in so
many decisions on things through the
pandemic a few other aspects
um whereas with this trust she's
definitely won lots of plaudits uh from
the base for the um for what she's done
as foreign secretary the trade deals but
it means we've got uh less of an idea on
how she would you know tackle domestic
issues we know where she is
ideologically but how does that work
when you're actually the one in charge
so i think there's probably a little bit
more of a sense that you know what
you're getting with rishi zumac just in
a sense will liz trust be as radical as
she says she is going to be i think
that's still an unknown
and on the on uniting the party i think
you've got a reminder of how difficult
it's going to be at pmq's today as boris
johnson left tory mp stood up to
applaud him a kind of standing ovation
that the um uh organized by robert
goodwill who's one of british students
backers of unity gesture
theresa may
stayed sitting for quite a while and
then got up and didn't clap and i mean
she's very much i can do an impression
she's still stood like this i know
i and when you have changed leader three
times in six years it does inject a
certain amount of poison into the
bloodstream
and that will be quite uh and that will
be a challenge for
any new leader
um and but i mean the one thing that i
would say
i was actually going to say two things
uh one is eat your heart people you can
you know because this is going to the
members that no one has dropped down you
know there will yeah
and if the uh
sorry i'm not gonna say that but
let's talk about david cameron and david
davis when david cameron and david davis
went to the country i they i think it
was safe to say that no one thought they
were bosom buddies but actually by the
end of this tour in the country doing
all these hustings you know they had
actually kind of um they actually were
kind of like an old theatrical couple
they could have finished each other's
sound bites they knew what they were
and and they actually got on like until
they got on when david cameron set up
his shadow cabinet surprisingly well
much better than people would have
expected so there is a chance that that
happens um although i think this contest
is more fiercely contested than that one
more and looking more blue and blue this
time i mean it looks pretty vicious
between the two already right and i
think i think the two do genuinely
now this could you vlog you makes it
less personal in some ways but there is
a genuinely
really big ideological disagreement
between them you know in in
in terms you know rishi sunak is a
thatcher right liz tross is a reaganite
you know richie zunak believes that you
know in sound money that you've got to
have tax cuts you've got to be paid for
uh liz trust thinks that you know the
deficit can be you know she she is much
more relaxed about letting the deficit
take the strain and things that kind of
trying to get growth going is the most
important thing above all
i i would argue that you know there are
some differences between between the the
uk and the u.s you know the uk is not a
global result currently not for global
reserve currency but you know this is
clearly going to be the ideological
debate of this campaign
now a couple of questions then we're
going to have to wrap this up so let's
try and get through them break next
speed a bit like the parliamentary
rounds of this contest um i'll only
think i'll take this one do you think
theresa may could come back into
government in an attempt to unite the
party
great question james maybe you can just
do a facial expression rather than
answer that i think i mean i mean i
think of all the the the prediction i
think that is relatively unlikely i
think very unlikely under liz trust and
also unlike the under ishizunak i
actually think if we're thinking what
the new cabinet's going to look like i
think there'll be a big drive to bring
in some of the younger intakes some
fresher faces um given all the turmoil i
think one of the ways given both the
candidates are quite experienced and are
tied to boris johnson cabinet decisions
i think one of the ways you will try and
move on and make the government seem
different is by having quite a new
cabinet i also think that in terms of
party management i think one thing i
think one thing that both of them have
said they will do they've talked about
appointing on merit which is kind of
code for a broader span of the party
being been in the cabinet that has been
the case in recent years
and on that someone has asked is there
something potentially undemocratic of
the mps taking penny morden and kevin
badenock out at this round when polls
have shown they're the most loved by the
members now it's probably worth pointing
at the penny what it was very loved last
week seemed to go down a bit this week
um because there is so much volatility
but i understand the point of this
question and
do you think that they've done members
of disservice i i think that um jeremy
corbyn showed that if you do not have
the backing of your parliamentary
colleagues it is very difficult to lead
your party
i also think that the i also think mps
do see
uh
these candidates up close
and i mean you know they are providing
them with a choice of two
uh and so
and i don't mean that is an unreasonable
uh choice to provide them with and i
think you know
i think also you have to remember this
which is
something that i think can be quite
easily forgotten you know if the tories
were in opposition you could argue that
there should be this con
if it through an opposition i would say
that this time table has been absurdly
short and you know you should have
waited you should have had a kind of
hosting's a party conference and then
mp's vote as happened in 2005. but the
tories are in government and you have to
have a prime minister of authority again
because you know this country is by
september we'll have three crises coming
at it you know there will be the kind of
current economic crisis there will be an
energy crisis just look at the fact that
when uh nordstrom won the russian gas
pipelines of germany's turn back on
again tomorrow the expectation is that
the russians you know they'll turn on a
little but not very much because they
don't want uh the germans to be able to
build up a stockpile of gas for the
winter um and so you know we're clearly
going to have an energy crisis in europe
because of the war in ukraine the
russian invasion of ukraine and the
russian attempt to use energy as a
weapon
um
and you have a very very volatile global
security environment you obviously have
a war in europe right now russia
invading ukraine and you also have um
china declaring for example but the
taiwan strait is not international
waters it's a domestic waterway so you
know i i i mean i think providing the
members with two experienced cabinet
instances of choice is not fundamentally
unreasonable okay now i really want to
get through these because we don't take
too much everyone's time so
um final
round of questions
um let's go first with this one james
perhaps you can shed some light is there
any suggestion as to who each candidate
would appoint as their chancellor
i think that is not clear at the moment
somehow
i mean i i think that you would think
that trust the two obvious candidates
would be quasi-content the business
actually is backing her and simon clark
she's actually the treasury who's also
backing her but you know i don't mean i
mean i think and i don't mean anything
it's totally obvious if you see what i
mean in the you know when david cameron
was running for leader it was quite
obvious that george osborne was going to
be his shadow chancellor um i i you know
when tony blair was running for leader
it was infamously famous called brown
was going to be his um shadow chancellor
i i don't think it is obvious right now
who each candidate would pick what who
do you think the contenders are for
rishi sunak
um i mean that is a very interesting
question and
i would
not be comfortable having a guess
because
i think he will want someone who shares
his fiscal conservation could that be a
steve barkley type figure i mean steve
barkley's gone from boris johnson to
backing him so that that's contented
yeah maybe i mean i i mean but i think
if you look at radeem sahari he hasn't
backed anyone could be he might be about
to lose his job but i mean i think i
think if you see
i think if you i think i think in some
ways because of this trust
like
quasi-consent is very committed to what
you could call trustanomics right you
know he is a big you know uh he said on
today's program you know that i i'm
going to paraphrase you know you
shouldn't be obsessed with balancing the
books you know that is very much the
kind of the kind of trostonomics view
um
and so i think it is easier that i think
i mean the the
richest unique is to my mind less clear
who he who who would be his contenders
for that job maybe he could do both
um
during the golden brown joke about that
uh gordon brown and his last budget
whole thing about gladstone and bradson
have tried to be both prime minister and
chancellor uh and it was intended it's a
joke but the problem was but
relations were a fraught on the labour
front bench at the time um as he was
about to take over from tony blair and
you could see them all look like they
sort of the lemon because they actually
think actually 40 was serious that he
was intending to do both jobs watch this
space
now penultimate question what are the
chances of an early general election if
the winning leader cannot solve the
economic problems facing the country now
all the candidates have said they don't
want an early election and then multiple
hustlings they've done
um but
do you think there's a chance they don't
have a choice in the matter they can't
lead um i i think the only election is
this idea that that will not die despite
how many times casey you and i
repeatedly try and slay it um
right
just just just just to to back up the
track this new prime minister will
inherit a majority of close to 80 right
not everyone will necessarily play ball
no not everyone will necessarily play
ball but i also think if you look at the
economy look at what um the governor of
the bank is at the mansion house last
night he was predicting
but by 2024 the economy would be
recovering strongly i think
it would seem to be very politically
perverse not to give as long as possible
for inflation to wash through the system
totally rely get a bit of growth back
be able to do some of the tax cuts uh
and then go to the country and say
october 2024 i think it would be i i i i
cannot see any argument for a new tory
prime minister going big leader
um i think even though he's a big
leaders band i mean one of the things
that you saw no no no i think one of the
things that you saw from theresa may
is given the severity of the situation i
think it would be quite hard even if you
got a big bounce to say by the way i
know we're dealing with three crises
simultaneously but i thought i'd just
chuck a general election in that it just
i just don't see how
how it works and i think it's not
something that it's not something that
tory mp ultimately for theresa may you
know even the vicar's daughter could not
resist the temptation of what was it a
24 28-point opinion poll lead i mean i i
don't think even the most um
the most optimistic backers of of of
ivor richie local distrust would claim
that if you elected their candidate the
tories will be 28 points ahead by
christmas um now the final question is
actually a personal one to both of us um
so thank you for asking about our
welfare and any summer holiday plans
guys or is it too soon to think that
someone will be a lull
um
uh
the the the the front loading of a
contest i think can justify my my
planned week and off in the middle of
august in france right now it's more
than one week uh no the second week is
in the late district but i'm i'm quite
that old so that that that i think could
be kind of you know these hustlings are
all going to be screened so there'll be
no need to kind of sweat around the
country yeah i'm hoping to disappear for
a few days but we'll see um thank you
very much for joining us today and we'll
be back later on as this contest goes on
with more updates and so thank you for
joining for this special edition of
spectator tv
[Music]